hey guys joe from food wars just wanted  to pop in and let you know that we are  officially starting a new food wars  season with a new country that's right  coming soon to the food wars cinematic  universe is food wars usa versus  india you may know him from his netflix  india show menu please please welcome to  the food wars family nikhil what's up  guys my name is nikhil kinney and i'm so  excited to be joining the food wars  hosting team india a land filled with a  million flavors delicious cuisines and  here i am to talk about kfc mcdonald's  burger king starbucks and many more it's  going to be a blast professional fast  food taster baby let's get it that's  right food wars usa versus india coming  to you real soon right here on food  insider so be sure to subscribe so you  never miss an episode